-Our next guest is
the co-founder and CMO
of the Premier Lacrosse League
and current professional
lacrosse player
with the Cannons Lacrosse Club
The PLL just kicked off
its third season on June 4th
and is available to stream
on Peacock.
Please welcome to the show
Paul Rabil.
♪♪♪♪
[ Applause ]
Welcome, Paul.
Thank you for being here.
-Thanks for having me.
-Really appreciate it.
Come on up.
-So excited to be here.
-This is a very
big deal for us, Paul.
I'm just going to come
right out and let you know
you are the first
professional lacrosse player
we've ever had on the show
-I'm flattered.
-And it's -- Now, what dre
you to playing the sport
when you were a young man?
-What drew you to having a
professional lacrosse player
on "Late Night?"
-Well, I guess that's
a bigger question.
-I started lacrosse
when I was 12.
My neighbor gave me
his backup stick.
I hated it --
few people know that --
because I was pretty bad at it
And then I owe my mother a
great deal of thanks,
because she would
drive me to practice
for that first full year.
And I was kicking and screaming.
I was crying.
I only cried, really, in sport
Then I got through it,
figured it out.
And I think lacrosse, whic
you'll find out in a little bit,
is like an amalgamation
of all the best sports
in the world.
-You -- 12 strikes me as lat
for any professional athlete
in any sport, to pick it up.
Is that common for people in
lacrosse or is 12 late?
-12 is late.
Especially nowadays, there's
a lot of sport specializatio
in any sport.
So, I grew up in Maryland,
and people consider
Maryland and New York hotbeds,
but it's really
Long Island and Baltimore.
So, there wasn't much --
There was no YouTube
or anything,
ways to learn the game.
So we all just figured it ou
with our imagination.
But overall, like, getting a
opportunity to compete
and have fun in a new game
and then excel.
Towards the end of my career
which kind of now,
as I'm 35 sitting here
like, "I'm gonna retire,"
is playing the game
for a different reason.
-It would be heartbreaking i
the first lacrosse player
we had on retired on our show.
-Should be break this right now?
-This would be really bad.
So, You -- There was an existing
lacrosse league, MLL.
-Yeah.
-You started PLL.
What inspired or what did yo
think was necessary
for there to be
a new breakaway league?
-Yeah, so, again, surprise -
I'm the first
professional lacrosse player
given that the game
had been around 20 years.
But Major League Lacrosse
had existed,
and our wages were, on average
$8,000 for the season.
So it was a lot like
the NFL players of the '60
that had multiple jobs,
no healthcare, no distribution
And we felt like maybe the bes
way to explain it is what
UFC did to MMA 20 years ag
is what we're
hoping to do to lacrosse -
professionalize, commercialize
it, bring it to the masses
So we did the NBC deal and w
got the games distributed.
We invested in social media,
which is a big difference
between starting lacrosse
in 2020
versus Major League Baseball
in the 1900s,
where the main medium
was newspapers and radio.
So we have
all of these advantages
and we wanted to
take advantage of those.
We increased the wage profile.
We're the only team-sport
league in North America
to offer our players equity.
-That's fantastic.
And you started it
with your brother.
-Yeah.
-How has that been?
I work with my brother.
It is more upside than downside.
Have you found it
to be the same?
-So, slightly more upside.
The upside actually is --
so, Mike is our C.E.O.,
and he does a fantastic jo
running the business day-to-day.
But when we were building it and
we just had a five-page deck
going to investors,
trying to cobble money
together to start a league
there was so much to do.
We would share hotel rooms
book them last minute
on, like, HotelTonight,
and we'd end up with a king bed.
So we'd share a bed.
Can't do that with a co-founde
that you're not familiar with.
-That's true.
-And -- But we have
a history of working together.
When we were younger,
we shoveled driveways.
We did pop-up lemonade stands.
And then he uses his
hands more in manual labor
He worked at a place calle
Roberts Oxygen
and scooped ice cream
at Maggie Moo's.
And I took my
entrepreneurial skill set
to Beanie Babies, actually
-Oh, wow! Look at that.
-Yeah, I was really
heavy into the trade,
had $10,000 worth of
Beanie Babies
and held on to them all.
-What are they worth now?
What do you think?
-Zero.
-Zero dollars.
-Yeah.
-That's good. That's good.
Well, that speaks well
for the future of this league.
-Right, right.
Yeah, so, can we
cut that segment?
Our investors
are probably nervous.
-The guy who was
in on Beanie Babies is now
"This is the next
Beanie Babies."
-Right, right.
-You played in Atlanta
this week,
because your league is
a touring model.
-That's right.
-You take eight teams
around so, you know,
people in different cities
can get this experience.
-Mm-hmm.
-You were in Atlanta
and on you had a clip
that made it on "SportsCenter.
And I should note that,
in Atlanta,
you guys were raising money fo
When We All Vote, is it?
-That's correct.
-And let's take a look
at this clip.
-There you go.
Alright, number 9.
Premier Lacrosse League --
Whipsnakes and Cannons.
Paul Rabil finding
Curtis Corley.
Look at Curtis.
So, the save is deflected
up in the air.
Rabil is the one who snags it.
-Now, first of all,
congratulations
on "SportsCenter."
Second of all, why the
touring model instead of having,
you know, eight different team
in eight different cities?
-Well, what we felt like,
you know, as entrepreneurs
we needed to look at
the sport objectively.
And there's 2 1/2 million
players, 10 million fans,
and so to launch
this bottom-up business
in markets all over the country,
we didn't think the sport
was quite there yet.
But we knew with
that density of fans,
that if we took the game
around the country
and grew it that way, that w
would have a better chance
The other thing is,
with NBC and other network
we were pitching at the time
distribution
and programming windows
are really difficult to secure
So, in team sports,
you have this
home-and-away schedule model
And we didn't want to deal
with the nuance of that.
So we went to
the network and said,
"What are your free window
on NBC and NBC Sports?" --
that are available,
I should say.
And they said, "This time on
Saturday, this time on Sunday.
I'm like, "Great.
We'll book them."
Because we take over the venue
for the whole weekend,
so it's kind of
an inside-out approach.
But I do think, in the future,
we will be city-based.
-That's exciting.
I do want to take advantag
of having you here...
-Okay.
-...for a little bit
of a tutorial.
We have a couple of
sticks behind you.
-Yeah, we do.
-And here we go.
Okay, so, yeah, actually,
I brought this one for you
-Okay, great.
-This is my game stick...
-...we saw that highlight on
So hopefully I can
do something like that here.
-I feel like my crew
has insulted me
by how close they've
put this goal.
-Yeah, this is, like,
what we would call
a crease attackman.
-Okay.
-So you can shoot and scor
from here.
I think I was there.
-Okay.
-But we talked
a little bit backstage.
You grew up in New Hampshire
You went to Northwestern.
So, shout-out to the
Northwestern women's team.
-Thank you very much.
-They're really good.
-I'll pass that on to them
-Yeah.
-I should point out
that I am not a good athlete
but I'm an
excellent impressionist.
So I feel like I'm
just going to follow
what you do,
and this should work out great
-Well, it's obvious.
So, your hand position
was already right.
So that's, like, the first step.
And we do
what's called cradling.
So, basically,
to keep the ball in the net,
you have to cradle
in this motion.
-Yeah.
-So, you got it there.
And then, as you get
a little bit more talented
you can one-hand cradle.
-Uh-huh.
-You can spin the stick.
-Okay.
-You can drop it in one hand
You can try the stick trick,
like that.
-Sure, sure, sure, sure.
-Almost.
-Yeah, yeah, yeah.
-And you can actually --
I think --
I've got to
check the rule books.
I did help write them, but
I think you can use your han
to pick the ball up.
It just doesn't make much sense,
because you'll get checked
-Yeah, yeah. I don't want that
Okay, great.
-Alright, so, let's shoot.
-Okay, great.
-So, you're a natural righty
-Mm-hmm.
-I can tell.
-Yeah.
-You know how I can tell?
-Yeah. Why's that?
-Because it's already
in your right hand.
-There you go.
-Alright.
So, you have
your hand position here.
And it's basically
like a catapult.
So you pull down
with your bottom hand
and you push with your top hand.
-Son of a...
-Yeah.
-Now -- Oh, the net.
-The net.
-Okay, I'm sorry.
I thought you said window.
-So, we'll give it a second try.
-I thought you said
highest window.
-Yeah.
-Alright, show me again.
-So, point your foot this time
in the direction
you want to shoot.
And then try to
keep it overhand, we tell kids
And then,
the further you reach back
like a catapult,
the higher it will go,
so let's not
reach back that far,
and just throw it there.
Boom. There we go.
-Alright.
I feel like we can
do better than that.
Hold on. Last one.
-Alright, alright.
-This time,
I'm going to put it in the net
but I'm never going to tak
my eyes off you.
-There you go.
-Alright, there we go.
-Yeah, and I can take
a huge shot,
but I don't want to risk,
you know,
hitting these expensive lights
-Oh, my God. Thank you.
Because they did tell us.
NBC made it very clear --
break it, you buy it.
You guys, you can stream
the Premier Lacrosse League'
current season on Peacock.